of all the projects that you worked on
between the intervention
and this which would you say had the
biggest influence on your skills as a
director
working with a a director like rodrigo
garcia who i've had the privilege of
working with several times or even my
experience on argo
you know seeing the way certain
directors handle
themselves on set and then the effect
that has on not only the cast but also
the crew and what the environment
feels like um you know that really was
an inspiration for me just in terms of
like the kind of set i wanted to have
and how i wanted my actors to feel um
where you know everyone felt safe and
protected um
and able to do their best work and
knowing that like no matter what i had
their back and that i was there for them
for whatever they needed we don't talk
about how important that is
nearly enough very first feature
screenplay is a very
very big deal i know you're a creative
individual in general
but what was it about writing a feature
screenplay
that might have surprised you well i was
very lucky and
and i feel so grateful that clea asked
me to
write this idea with her um because i
learned
so much from writing with clia but then
also
watching the care and the
the the focus that she brings to the
stories that she tells it
one of the biggest lessons i took was
like how
crucial it is and how important it is to
to have every scene feel like it has a
purpose within the story that was a big
lesson that i learned in
in watching clea like shape this story
as we were writing it
um the yeah the amount of attention to
detail and the crafting of it was
was so inspiring to to see even having
worked on the screenplay
is there anything that you didn't even
realize about jane until you hit the set
okay so many things jane really uh
i yeah she really just came to life
in me in a way that was um was so
fun i i in writing jane we knew that we
wanted her to be this
this joyful character and this this
person who just really uh has such a
deep level of self-acceptance
um but they're being on set i was so as
jane just so excited that everyone was
in the room
like to be around everybody and that led
to this sort of
bouncy energy physically that was cool
to discover
on the set in those dynamics your
moments were some of my favorites
i am obsessed with the entire ensemble
so which two members
would you say had the most polar
opposite
prep processes that challenged you to
adapt to two completely different things
i think the biggest thing was just
working with kids you know having those
two kids and they were so
they did such a great job and came to i
was always terrified that they wouldn't
know their lines and they always did and
they always like knocked it out of the
park
and you know i think working you know
balancing that and working with them
like that's such a different style
working with kids than it is working
with
um grown-ups so that was i think that
was the biggest difference was really
like when they were around having to
adapt to the different styles for them
and also just we had to go so fast when
they were there
but like wanting to still keep not
having the kids feel the stress
of everybody being like they need to be
done yeah
and have them be clear on what needed to
happen like be able to explain it to a
child is such a specific skill
yeah so job well done in that department
and every other one i love the movie
congratulations to you both
thank you so much thank you